hi everyone um i am one's grandmaster
sabina feuscher you're watching
uh insane in the end games uh
tuesday night evening wherever you are
uh and uh let us get started
going what no
please work i did this
oh it's working okay all right
uh okay perfect i'm going to
just make sure i'm just flipping
flipping the board a little bit
all right so i thought for today's
class i'm going to be talking a little
bit about
um a book
that uh grand master el sharma radio
body and myself published it's called
sherlock's method
we wrote this book uh last year and it
got published um
september october uh we're really
excited
about it it has three different parts
where we we have like tactics and games
and uh complex uh decision making and
we wrote the book in a way to help
people get trained
uh get to train for a tournament
and i thought for today's class this is
my start
with the club with this particular theme
of end games i thought i would share
some of the positions that
um we have um prepared in the
uh in the book uh to kind of give you an
idea of what we had i thought uh
i picked um some of my favorite like
the first uh three of them are king and
poland games
i thought they go really well for
uh for today's class uh
and without further ado let us get
started and um
so this uh was an end game
that happened in the game between hikaru
nakamura
and bruzon lazaro
two very strong chess players and
it's a king and poland game so king and
pawn indians are always
you know fun fun to
to teach and to study i think because
you basically
um you don't have so many pieces
uh the lines are pretty clear you have
to
uh consider
who is going to promote first how you're
going to take your opponent's pawns
create your past pawns and uh hope your
pawn
is going to be promoted before the
opponent basically
okay it's never easy right because uh
opposition is very important
uh shouldering is also very important
sometimes triangulation
is a way to try to get uh to a position
that
is going to be good for you and you are
putting your opponent's king in zugsvang
so there are a lot of very important
themes that you have to know before you
are able to solve
uh king and pawn end games for example
with more pawns right
did you start with king and pawn versus
king and then you add more pawns and
anyways so
in this end game it is black to move and
uh
you have to figure out what exactly it
is that you want to do with black in
order to win
temples by the way temples are also very
important
in king and pawn and games especially
with pawns on both sides of the board
because sometimes you want to make a
pawn push
and um and you think it's
uh
it's going to be helpful for you but
sometimes it can be helpful for the
opponent so anyways
right now the kings are around this
f5 pawn black of course wants to win
that pawn and um
white would love to have it traded so
that they can bring their king
on the queen side win these pawns and
win the end game
so very simple but it is black to move
so if you were to choose
what to do here in this position with
black
take your time a little bit and think
which move you're going to play
you have a couple of choices let's think
about it
simple one maybe well i already see some
people
suggesting moves c6 certainly c6 is one
move
b5 is one move uh and then there's one
more move that's important
well b5 actually right now it really
doesn't work so much c6 and then there's
one more
which is king g5 these two moves make
lots of sense
of course g6 does not make any sense as
i said if these two pawns get traded for
white it is very easy
just bring in their king on this side of
the board and they just win the end game
so we definitely don't want that for
black
often times you're told that in kingdom
ponen games if your king is in the
center and you're more advanced you
should be winning
but it's not really just like that
really um
the way you have your pawns placed and
and how weak they are can matter too
triangulation is yeah so a lot of people
are suggesting
uh c6
but actually the correct move here is
king g5
let's just see what's happening after c6
because this happens to be a blunder
so you're thinking to play c6 because
you want to make sure white does not
have the opportunity to go king d5
probably
and you're considering you want to play
b5 trading things here
possibly right or
i don't know what other way um
what that idea you can have but if you
do play this move c6
white is going to play king f4 and now
black's advantage is gone
that would have been the only advantage
and we will see it in a second where
where that
is and now you have to be careful with
black
not to be in zukzvan actually because
in some situations think about it if you
don't have moves with your pawns on this
side of the board
then he's going to push you back right
you can push your king back then he'll
play f6
be forced to trade the pawn which is
something we discussed
briefly or really fast then he will
trade
and then white's king will just march on
the other side of the
board grab all your pawns and you're
going to be losing
so you definitely do not want to do that
think about it that way
if you're not careful for example you
play b5 right that would be a huge
blunder because
white plays which move
can anyone yes it's a blunder i already
have it
already it's i'm sharing some of this
stuff like i said from the book
uh you will find a lot of very
interesting positions like this and it's
not just king and pond and games it's
plenty of end games
for today's class i chose king and pawn
and games because i find them
a little bit easier and the ones that we
should start with
uh here the correct move for white
is c5 no we are not going to take in b5
because if we do pawn takes
then you know here an africa king g5
king e5 and we don't quite have a way
for black to improve
we just go back and forth and this is
going to be a draw
but c5 indeed after b5 white is going to
play c5
and um and the point is that now you're
on a zoox van your king has to go back
we've already discussed that g6 is not
such a great move
because y just enters grabs these pawns
and wins the game
so we have to go back and now the
correct move
for white to win in this position is
king to g5
no we will not go to e5 we will go to g5
king e5 would allow for the opposition
and you do not have a way to enter and
no more
temple moves but you're going to go king
to g5 and now
uh no matter what we do with black
there's that specific idea that i've
already mentioned king g6
f6 trading the pawns and white skin is
on the same rank
as your uh weaker pawn of the chain
and once that gets captured you're
losing with black
so it's kind of crazy from from a
position that you should be winning
which
was basically the starting position you
will end up losing
going back to c5 this is basically
so that you know how the game finished
black played king here white play king
e5
king d7 f6
g takes f6 king takes f6
and now white is winning because they
reached
as i said the rank of the pawn and now
there is that
you know typical idea uh of approaching
like a zigzag i like to call it uh so
for example if you go here
here here here go back comes here
you defend come here right so i did
basically
do some kind of a zigzag oops it was the
other way around
and now you have no place to move the
king to keep the pawn protected that you
lose it
and that's it done this is the way the
game ended after king takes f6
um white is winning
and it was the result of the game
between hikar nakamura and
uh lazzaro represent
now there was this interesting choice
actually here after f6 for black to play
g6
and the idea was that now white would
play f7
king e7 promotion king takes
um and this probably
this is kind of interesting because now
if you're cooking f6
g5 takes now king g7 black could have
been able to make a draw
in this position because you do not
actually have an entrance
to reach this pawn
but
in this position white can try king d6
and then after um after g5
king takes c6 g4
king b7 for example here here
here here queen queen
now this is a little bit unclear
personally i mean i believe this should
be a draw
but of course white is going to try to
to fight more for
for a win um but it's not as clear as
they want
the other position here that i believe
there are lots of chances to try to make
a draw
uh but uh given that this game was
played in 2020 or was played online
entrance.com what to do the game
uh ended in a loss for black going back
to the starting position
right we did see c6 was not such a great
idea it was maybe a natural way
of stopping what thought what black
thought to be white's threat
but in fact here he's actually winning
with this beautiful move king g5
maybe it's not way counterintuitive as
you fear this move but really white
cannot really do that because
you know you just you just give up this
pawn and then black just marches
black's g pawn is much faster than
anything here
um if instead of king d5 white tries
some move like this
it just loses to capture and then if you
go here
we go c4 and then
say you just sit and wait here
black can win by circling around this is
like
one of my favorite uh ideas i think in
inking and pawn and game the fact that
you can circle around with the king
and by doing so you're shouldering and
you're pushing the opponent's king down
and then you get to actually come back
to to grab the
the material and this if you ever play
f6 it will be a trade and then black's
king will go
first these pawns and win the end game
like in this position you play king e5
which is the move that makes the most
sense
uh in this case take a moment and think
about this position if you are
um if you are
if you have the time if you are watching
this video later this is something you
probably
want to pause on and and think about the
correct move for black to win here
is c5
going to king g4 will not help actually
because there's f6
and here
sorry this is the correct move i
apologize
c4 is a blunder because after the
capture you you end up losing because
now we take this pawn but this is the
correct move for black
and the idea is that now black manages
to
play b5 trade the pawn here
and now we just keep the opposition this
is kind of a beautiful idea i think
because black just sits now wherever you
go we just keep the opposition and you
can never
get to take advantage of the fact that
you have an extra pawn i think this is
kind of gorgeous king c5
very nice move and
if you go for example king here you have
to be super careful because you can go
from a winning
i mean from a drawing position basically
because that's a draw with king b7
to a losing position because then i take
you go king b7 oopsie
whatever b7 or c7 and then king b3
you take the pawn i take the pawn you go
king c5
and you don't manage to get the king to
c3
so now black is the one winning you
always have to be
super super cautious inking and pawn end
games because you never know when you
can go from winning to losing to draw
to anything just a simple move like this
can
you think you're being um sneaky
and effect in fact you end up losing so
king b7 is the move
but then as i showed you there's this
beautiful
you know just uh opposition idea
blank just follows you around and you
can never like try to go on the other
side of the board
you know because um b4 is never going to
work
because i take ambassador with black and
then my pawn in b3 is much more advanced
than the a pawn
all right so going back to that move c5
why is this move so strong
well because now after c5 you kind of
have to sit and wait
if you go for example king d6 here we
we're cooking a four
and white is in zugsvang white needs to
give up this pawn
and you can give it up by planking if uh
seven
or pushing pushing makes the most sense
because you're keeping your king
kind of close by to the to the b pawn
and keeping the opposition
but unfortunately this is not sufficient
for you because look at this
and when you go king c6 black is much
faster
so he gets to take both of those pawns
and win
the game taking c5 take here and we've
had this position before
and instead of king e6 in this position
if white plays king e4
the way we're winning is once again
you're circling around
king to g4 you have to come king e5
and now we're going king f3 eventually
you do have to push this pawn and once
you do
we are out flanking you basically i
think this is the way
we call the circ i like to call it
circling a lot around
maybe you heard the term outflanking
more often than my circling around
whichever term you like is fine with me
as long as you know this idea of pushing
the opponent's king back
and getting to do what it whatever it is
that you need to do
and that was that this was the first end
game
and it's actually the first end game in
the in the
chapter in the part of end games
in our sherlock's method book
with that said uh we have a lot of
examples
but like i said i'm just going to share
some i cannot share the whole book
wouldn't be fair for those people for
for the people who actually do buy the
book
which i highly recommend you to do doing
a little bit of promotion because
you know i'm allowed i was allowed i
have asked for permission to do so
uh let's go to the next position and
actually
this is kind of interesting because it
seems like a very simple position and it
wasn't played by
um top players it was played by some
weaker players but it doesn't matter
because it doesn't matter which level
you're playing something if
if something is beautiful i think you
can create it
at any possible level you don't have to
be a top gm
to create beauty in chess
i think you can be at any level and
beautiful positions can be created
and you just need to
i don't know you just just need to enjoy
chess
um because it's uh it's a really nice
game i think
anyways uh let's get started with this
position
and uh i'm curious to see
your opinion how do we evaluate this
position
because well we have pawns on the same
side of the board both kings are pretty
active
this is not from san luis i'm actually
in romania i'm recording this from
romania
and it is guess what time 4am here
all right but let's talk about the
position and i'm really curious
to know what do you guys think who
should be winning or is the draw
what is happening in this position
i see some g4 g5 ideas
king e5 king f6 interesting
very interesting king e7 king f6 is also
a possibility right because when you go
to e7 you're actually going to take the
pawn
yeah for sure you know
this position is so tempting to believe
that white should be winning
i think when you first see it you you
are tempted to believe that white should
be winning i feel like
that's how you're thinking in this
position it's just why to move
i usually try to uh show a position from
the from the side whose turn it is so
that it makes it easier for everyone to
to choose what it is that you want to
play
it is a draw but guess what there's only
one move
there's only one move that makes draw
for white
which is kind of crazy because as i said
the kings are advanced the same way um
towards the the other side's
pawns and you may think it's super easy
to
uh to to make a draw but really it's not
moves that make most sense of course are
um what some of you have already
suggested king e7
king e5 uh g4 i don't know if i've seen
any f
pawn pushes but you could consider f
pawn push as well why not
um i think that's about it
and um
and so
black is not in time okay let's see
so we'll start with the blunders first
to understand what the problem is in the
position
i think the most natural move and the
one that was actually played by white in
this position
is king e7 and it's really a natural
move unfortunately it is a blunder
and white ended up losing after playing
here because
now you want to take the pawn right so
obviously black has to play a five
and then you realize that by the time
you go
take this pawn right
to try to get all of those pawns
he will be much faster because your
weakness is much closer to black skin
than his
weakness is to yours and so if you play
f4 to try to make your
weakness a little bit further away here
e3
f6 king f3 kg7
takes takes and now
and now take a moment and think which
pawn black is going to capture
i hope you're capturing the correct one
and
that correct pawn is actually the pawn
in h3
that is the one you should capture that
is what happened in the game
and black ended up winning we are
capturing the one that
white is going to create as a past pawn
that's very important
you always want to take the pawn of the
opponent that is bothering you
or could bother you in a way here if you
take this one
uh king takes g6 actually in that
position white resigned but after king
takes g6 obviously king g4
and you grab that pawn and you win the
the end game
um clearly not taking this
one because this is giving white the
opportunity
to save themselves now because they can
promote the h pawn two
right so this is what's happening
clearly the pawns are of the same rank
black promotes first but they don't have
the opportunity
their king is not close enough to
actually uh win here
keep uh white's king on the edge and and
have a
checkmating idea so this is going to be
a draw okay
everything is pretty much forced after
king e7 and like it makes total sense
for
for black to push if we try to go king
f6 in this position
black will play king e2 still going for
this pawn and if you go king g7
obviously
we take take and then that f pawn just
marches
if you push now we are basically going
back to the previous line
and there's no wait for no way for white
to do much
if g4 we can just either take here or
take an f4
then we take here and one of these two
bones will be winning
but that was that was what happened in
the game
in e5
falls for something very similar kingit2
back in the pawn
and now uh if you if you try to just
keep the king closer it's not going to
help you much king takes f2
if you go g4 black will keep attacking
you
and it's not like you're actually able
to to do much here
whichever pawn you push black will have
the extra pawn with which they will win
so the correct move as some of you have
pointing
pointed out already is g4 but this is
the only move that
works the reason this is the only move
that works
is you are keeping your your weakness
this would be weakness the black will
try to go all the way there to take
right
really far away so by the time the skin
goes there
it will take a long time so you will
actually have this at the time to
to save yourself so now um
kingdom two of course and now f4
this is an important move king of three
and maybe now i can give you one minute
to think about what you're going to do
next
with white what was the reason of all
this
and the reason is
the reason is uh why not you we'll we'll
see king e4 as well we will look at
kinky four as well
f5 indeed uh not king e5 this would be a
blunder for white if you play king e5
because um you are wasting time king g3
you're wasting time
and now if you're looking f6 he can take
either one of these pawns and black is
still winning because once again we're
dealing with a
kind of far away past pawn
but not king e5 but f5 so white manages
to trade this pawn
uh g takes f5 uh
king g3 would allow for this beautiful
move after which white is winning
most likely i think because now if you
take
we go g5 first very important
because we're making black a
two moves before starting to push the h5
upon
the h pawn right we don't go king
this is very important every single
tempo matters
i chose these positions because i felt
it will really show
how important king and pawn and games
are and how simple you think they can
be but no they're are
nuances that you have to consider each
step of the way and now if that happens
h5 that's the move for black first h5
uh if you take takes
takes here king somewhere
and then king g2 and yeah you get to
promote first and i don't get to promote
but for those of you who are familiar
with this this is a draw because
white king is not advanced enough in
order to create that
that mating idea and this is the h pawn
so
this is a draw
um so h5 very important move and if you
try to play g5
h4 you take we can try to get into this
position but this
also should be a draw
you do have the queen and you do have an
extra pawn but this most likely
will end in a draw
after f6 h5 that's an option
that's not maybe that draws as well as
well here
h5 uh
[Music]
yeah i think this draws two because we
can probably
we're probably getting into a similar
position takes take skinny seven
takes takes h4 and
yeah the this leads to the the same kind
of idea as before
queen here draw because if white's king
would have been
in g5 white would be winning in order to
be able to win these
h or a pawns the king has to be two
squares away from g3
uh because that's how you put the king
on the back rank and then you have the
mating
idea even when black promotes hopefully
everyone is familiar with that
okay f5
and black has to play g takes f5
pawn takes f5 and now um
very important i guess it doesn't matter
king f4
both king f4 and king e4 work king f4
and now now
only one move draws once again we're
getting into a position where
only one move draws for white and you
have two of them
1 f6 2 and e7
i'm curious which one you guys are
choosing
to play here which one of them
one wins the other one loses
i hope you're choosing the right one
and the right one is king e7 you need to
get that pawn in order to make a draw
you're getting the f pawn with the h
pawn black will not be able to win
good very nice i i like your guys i like
the way you guys think
uh f6 is a blunder f6 is a blunder don't
worry we'll see it in a second
here here and black cannot win this
because for example if you play h5
what does y do white needs to get
the opposition right the shouldering so
whenever black has to win the h
pawn white needs to make it to take the
opposition so you don't care about going
king g7 you don't get care about playing
h4 the more
you push the pawn forward the easier you
make it
for the other side to win because they
take your pawn really fast
move the king away from in front of the
pawn and then they promote
so you do not want to do that you're
going to play the correct move which is
king e7
because what you need to do is like i
said you're trying to come around like
this
and take the opposition when time
happens so here
here king f4 king d5
king g3 k4 takes king f3
draw okay so it's not
important to go try to get the pawn
because you'll never get it you circle
around
okay this is a big theme that
is my emphasis for today's class
hopefully it was pretty clear
so far going back
to that f6 point right so i said king e7
was the correct choice and there is no
way for black to try to win here
clearly they have to take the f5 pawn
and then go for the h3 pawn
but you saw white makes it in time f6
would have been a blunder
exactly you don't push the pawns unless
you're sure of things you should
calculate anyways
here here king g6
these are mind squares
one of my favorite king and pawn and
game themes
besides the circling around which i keep
making and i keep making this
i don't know why but um
mine squares are amazing because if
you're not careful you lose
i mean whoever gets on the mine square
first loses clearly
uh now you cannot move the king anywhere
you need to stay there to keep your f6
pawn protected so you have to play h4
and now black plays the move h5
putting you in zuksman there's nothing
you can do now you need to move the king
black takes the f6 pawn after which they
win the game obviously it would be
terrible
super terrible for black to play h6
because now it would be
white who puts them in zuk's van by
pushing h5
check you need to move the king
most likely take and after that we go
there we promote and white is winning
so h5 correct move
zuk zonk we need to move the king we
take the phone and we win
so that was that going back to the
starting position it's kind of crazy
but g4 was the correct move
for white to actually keep the position
balanced then just
make a draw some of you were asking me
previously
why king e2 why not king e4 there's no
big difference between the two just that
of course with king e2 we allow f4
with this move we do not allow f4 but
with king 2 we did have a threat to
actually capture the pawn and white was
pushing
it this way we are actually not having
any threat we need two moves to go grab
the pawn
so white has the time to go attack this
pawn as well
okay so when now king e7 and then um
and you have to play f5 you don't have
time to working f3 because white will be
faster
so to be a blunder here here and then if
you take
we go king g7 king g3 for example
and now g5
and we're dealing with the same thing as
before and if king h4
king h6 is bank once again the king
needs to move
and we take here and white is winning
so in this position after k7 f5 is the
correct move
and now for white king f6
keeping the attack on the pawn um
if you take ink
h5 will not do anything because
obviously we can take take
king here in here draw
and if you play a four well i think we
have multiple ways for white to make a
draw but this is probably the most
straightforward one keeping the pawn
under attack
king of three h4
if you play h6 you can grab either one
of the pawns
and this
is going to be intro
and that was this end game so like i
said
you don't always and even if you know
you see a position and
don't necessarily look for positions
that are played by top level players
if you see an interesting position try
to see
uh try to understand it try to uh
just uh take the beauty of it
and um and you never know what
what nice material you can find in
everyone's game
awesome going on to our next
end game this is the next end game and
um
and this was played between
uh two grandmasters of course ash bin
jayaram
against conrad holt
another very interesting king opponent
game um you can clearly see
white's pawn structure is so much better
right um so they should have a better
end game but
you still have to consider how you're
going to try to improve in this position
with white
things are not so easy right
um i like this position because it's a
little bit
maybe not counterintuitive but it's not
an idea that you often consider
you're always told that it is so
important to bring the king to the
center
and um and there's always
the right way but really there's never a
right way the right way is the one that
actually helps you win
there's no nothing you know the right
way is only
only the one that makes you win or else
it's not the right way it's just
some way so um you need to understand
what it is that you want to do
and then find the fastest way to get
there okay
chess king first get get the king out
okay or or forking f2 you see
that's the natural approach there's a
natural approach that everyone is
considering
to bring in the king by king f1
or or pushing f4 but
but no the correct move in this position
would have been
king to h2 would have been the winning
move
and we'll talk about it why it is a
winning move and that's also something
of course that we discuss
in the book very much but in the game
um ashwin jerome played king f1
and it could have led to a draw things
went um a little bit differently but
if you if you do get the book there will
be a little bit more explanation than
this part
as to why you know and uh and el shawn
grandma stereo sramara diaboli came up
with this
uh very nice uh description here
as to what is happening here
but um k7
k2 king d6
ben feingold says always to move the
king yeah he does
he does i mean everyone will tell you
that is the most important thing to do
but
um anyways
that's him so king here and now king d3
king d5 right so black is the one who
actually manages to get the king
in the center first because they're a
little bit faster
and had you played f4 it would have been
the same thing
uh a3
or a4 those are your two options here
with white
uh a3 for example e5
and in this position black blundered
black played g5 in this position oops
sorry
after after f3 in this position black
played g5 which is a big blunder
you know when you're playing king and
pawn end games and pawns are not
blockaded and you have them on both
sides of the board
you should be very mindful on how you're
pushing your pawns forward because
usually you need those extra tempe
you need the time to to know when to
give the move to the opponent
if you're getting rid of your of two
moves right because g5 gets rid of two
two choices g6 and g5 right there too
you need to make sure that's okay right
and in this case black played it a
little bit too fast and now
white i'm gonna play day four
and uh white is winning here because now
you need to
find a way to to lose moves
for example like um
i know if you play b5 for example to try
to say oh
i have b6 here sure but look how many
how many moves i have i have b3 i have
b4 i have g3 i have g4
so many moves are right here and then
you push your h
pawn and then h4 and then at some point
you will let my king enter
if you go that way for example you let
making enter and white is way
faster than anything and white is
winning
we also have the entrance there
so after f3 d5
why did not play a4 why play b3
mistake now b5
taking you know getting this extra move
for themselves white waited here
a little bit thinking that will give the
move without actually pushing upon
a h5 g3
and here black actually made a final
mistake after which
they ended up losing they played h4
the correct move to draw and this is a
beautiful idea i think
because you need to understand how you
blockade the position
so that white does not have extra 10
piece to actually push your king back
and go forward so the correct move for
black in this position would have been
b4 the point is that now
if you take we go b5 so we have
blockaded these pawns
and not just that we basically have
created a fortress there's no entrance
for white's king
there's no entrance and if you play h4
we take take
and then king d6 and you go king e4 and
we go king e6
and you don't have an entrance if you
play f4 we trade
right and we maintain the opposition and
y does not have a way to enter despite
the extra pawn
there's no win this is going to be a
draw
so this would have been a really
beautiful idea you don't have any other
entrances
this simply gets to blockade the
position and draw and instead of
capturing here
if you're thinking with white that this
is a wiser decision
it's not going to to help do anything
because
black can just go back and if you look
in here
they will still play h4
take or or g4 to say oh i'm giving the
move okay but now black has this extra
move
and i have to go back and he's gonna go
kindly six
and um you do not have an entrance you
go here
we take the opposition this is very
important we take the opposition here
we take the opposition here here here
and this is a draw don't make the
blunder
in this position when white plays king
e3
don't make the blunder of planking king
d5
okay because you are thinking that this
is the only
important square whenever y goes to e4
you should go to e6
wrong because the position is not
completely located here like it was
in the previous line that i showed and
now if white goes king d3 uh
white actually has the opportunity to
enter this way and grab your pawn
so that would be a huge blunder please
be very mindful and
not make that blunder
yes it's a pretty double pawn sacrifice
i think it's really nice
so um
instead of g5 in that position
black should have played b5
and the point is that you know
with this move they're keeping this
extra tempo anyways that was a move
was supposed to be played right because
that pawn had to be
moved forward and then we get this b6
extra tempo move and we're maintaining
the option to play
either g6 or g5 depending on white is
playing
two tempos are very important once again
in king and pawn and games where there
are pawns on both sides of the board
and it's kind of it's not so clear
they're not located yet
and their potential entrance is for both
sides
i i'm not sure if black thought even at
a little bit that they had some chances
to win i don't think they should have
but in case they did it was
unfortunately wrong so b5
and then b3 for example now g5
because we're maintaining that extra
tempo g3
now this beautiful idea once again b5
and then you go in here h5 any g4 or h4
those can get traded and as i showed you
previously black manages to keep the
opposition and draw the game
so once again this is what happened the
game
once again i'll repeat how it went so
king f1
here here here white brother king so did
black
and unfortunately for black in this
position after
um after f3 they went for g5
okay and then b3 was played so white
missed the first time the chance to win
but black
messed up once again not with b5 but
with h
sorry actually didn't play b5 but here
after g3 they blundered
played h4 and after takes
this is how the game went
and this was played in san luis actually
white was able to enter it wouldn't have
mattered if black would have played b6
here to give the temple back because we
do have b4
and this idea to play b4 also wouldn't
have helped
i'm playing uh for example b5 here to
give the move because now compared to
before we actually
are on the rank of the pawn so here
white is able to take the pawn and win
the game
lots of blunders indeed i mean this
happens this happens sometimes
um what to do i mean it's uh it's life
it's
it's not it's not such an easy end game
and when you have a lot of palm pushes
it is very easy to make blunders even
top
strong grandmasters make them as you can
see here
we all make mistakes who is behind me
omg who is behind me
uh we're not we're not on april
april fools anymore we are i think it's
april 6
now so you guys cannot cannot trick me
with that with that
uh although i did look anyways
going back to the starting position so
king f1
could have allowed to that beautiful
draw where black was giving up that pawn
and then blockading the position with b5
but let's see the winning idea which
would have been
really really nice and i've seen this
happening in other top
players games i don't know if you guys
did see it or not
but if you didn't you can see it now
uh king h2 so let's see
you have seven obviously uh you can try
king e72 if you want
but there's no big difference here
here here here so we're still getting
the same thing
but now we have to say four so we're
making black out of moves
and if you try to activate your king
h4
this never works because it allows white
the opportunity to bring in the king
so you have to try to keep the position
as solid as you can and just wait
but white can can simply advance your
look
this is a line that we actually gave in
the book
and since you're just sitting and
waiting because you cannot move the king
away from there it allows y to enter
now white plays here f3
oops not f4 sorry f3 okay f4 i think
works too
king here now f4 you need to move the
king back
and white advances with their king
and now the move that wins the game
g5
and and here
[Music]
say you go back
white has plenty of extra moves on the
side of the board to make your king go
away and then their king is going to
be
[Music]
here for example b4 if you're looking f7
we enter from this side of the board if
you go king d7
we can take and enter from this other
side of the board
and white is winning
so going back to that position after
king here if black try to come on the
side of the board
and keep you restricted for example e5
and tries to kind of keep the position
solid
the correct move has always is always
going to be for why this a4 move because
with this move
white indeed does lose two tempes but in
the same time stops black spawns on the
queen side which
allows white to have plenty of extra
tempes something the black will not have
and then if you try some h5 he's gonna
lose to king of three
just sit and wait supposedly right to
take the opposition
and now you will run out of moves look
you cannot
you don't have pawn pushes anymore this
b5 will never work because we just take
and here we have plenty of moves with
white
like f3 f4 pretty much anything
waiting
waiting and g4
you have to sit and wait
and the correct move for white to win is
here and we have plenty of extra
10 p's as i said but we can play a
and we're only going to utilize our
extra tempe when we have the entrance
over here to this pawn so now we can
play b4
and your last try is b5 in case i take
to play b6 and hope that you will just
take the opposition but obviously i will
not take i'll play a5
you don't have the spawn push anymore
you need to move the king
and white is going to be able to
um to activate the king win the h
pawn and win the game
if black does not try to push the pawns
forward and goes for king
king f6 white can simply gain
space on the side of the board until
you're running out of
palm pushes and let's not forget he will
always have these extra moves
to give you the tempo you can sit and
wait
this is the line that we actually
suggested king f6 king e4 king e6 so far
so good if
we've gotten into this position before
black has to try to control these two
squares so that white cannot push you
back
but now f3 and eventually you have to
start pushing these pawns
and after that there's just h5
and if you play here here at some point
you need to let me enter on one of these
two sides and white is going to be
winning
um so these were the king and pawn end
games that i found you know the most
interesting and i felt that it's
important to kind of share with you
so that you understand how easily you
can blundering king opponent games
how important shouldering opposition uh
is um but also tempes like how you
keep your extra tempest with the pawn
how you don't always go towards the
center
by the normal way through f1 or push the
f pawn and bring the king sometimes
through h2 is actually
working better as you could see this way
for white
why was it better basically uh to go
through h2
because if he didn't you saw if he
didn't come that and you're also making
it a little bit
like on a better square f4 was a better
square than d3 which is
only as far as y could get normally
through f1
but here you are a little bit more
advanced and you saw how
by moving your pawns the right way white
does have
plenty more extra tampies and can push
black skin back
and white can go forward so this is
something very important
now i did start the class a little bit
late today so i'm going to give you an
extra position and this is like another
very beautiful
and favorite uh position of mine it's
not a king and pondering game it's
actually bishop versus pawns
and i find it really beautiful was
played between gwen jones
and dinara
and i i love this position from the book
i
wanted to make sure i included it and um
it seems simple at first but it's really
a little bit more complicated than that
i
i believe um so
um let's get let's get to it
um so in this position clearly
white um
um seems to be doing really well with
the extra piece but
black's king is close to actually
winning these two pawns
like clearly those two pawns will be
lost because they're on dark square
and
and because of that um we still have the
f
pawn and you may think with the bishop
and the f pawn you should be able to win
but let's not forget the black does have
three pawns that you have to stop
and it's not going to be easy and you
need the help of your king to actually
support the f pawn
which will stay past and in some
situations like
there are lots of drawing ideas
a few moves back when you read the book
you'll find out
about some mistakes that were happening
that
that happened before but
um but here it may seem like oh it's
just you know you you just want to go f4
and you think you are totally fine but
no because plex king is actually in the
box at this point
and after i take i'm actually in the box
and surprisingly or not you're actually
not able to win this
because blacks connected past pawns are
going to keep your king passive
and with their king they stop your f
pawn and it's actually
going to be a draw you cannot win this
you guys
uh can check it i promise there's no win
the king just goes there
pushes a5 like for example like
you cannot push it
if you push it like that right the king
comes to stop the pawn
and even if you bring in your king you
have to be super cautious he's gonna try
this
and this and he will just keep the pawns
in such a way that you will not be able
to win them
and of course i'm also threatening c4 so
you need to move the bishop
and then a5 and you will not be able to
use the king to bring in the king to
support your f pawn because you have to
stay
here in case black starts pushing the
pawns to give up the bishop
and make a draw so
the correct move in this position
is i didn't see anyone actually
oh no someone did say it
bishop d5 indeed indeed someone did say
it
it is bishop d5 so you're taking
advantage of a small tactical idea
to try to get your bishop on a better
place square um
and um bishop d5 okay
starting point of this if you take
you're going to lose very simple so
we're not going to consider that this is
a past pawn
nobody's uh
wait i know it seems very simple but
wait it's not over that's what you think
but it's not over king takes b4 now
bishop takes c6
king takes c5 right so
trust me if it would be that easy
uh i mean it seems like it's easy
because white managed to take that pawn
right now they are just two pawns
they have the f3 pawn and um
should be very simple very simple win
you may think very this is very
suspicious
this is very suspicious indeed because
there are not so many moves that win
this
there are not so many moves that win
this in the game uh white play bishop e4
okay and uh let's see what happens so
that you understand
why there's only one move that wins for
white bishop e4
this is a blunder because now king d4
all right you cannot push the f pawn
so bishop c6 king e3
bring in the king bishop c6 so that
you're you're
you know keeping the pawn under attack
so you could try to win it if i push a5
but i can still push a5 you cannot take
it because you lose that one
you are bringing in your king and black
plays
a4 okay black plays a4
you can never take this pawn so you're
gonna go king b4 and guess what
king of four you cannot take this pawn
because if you do will push
right and then you have to stop the pawn
with the bishop will sacrifice take this
draw
so what will you do just sit
and i just sit and wait back and forth
back and forth
kind of funny or not um it's funny that
black manages to make a draw it's not so
funny for white who is hoping to win
because they do
have an extra bishop right
so this is a fortress
incredible when i saw this i was looking
so many times we tried to use the engine
and everything to to make sure we're not
mistaken
but this is a fortress there's no way
for right to win
as if you're moving the king to try to
approach the a pawn will go
so you don't manage to protect your pawn
with the king and then with the bishop
to stop those pawns and
you don't manage to do that so there's
no progress here
and the game ended in a draw after a
couple more moves
of repetition takes takes takes
and the the players agreed on a draw
but guess what in this position actually
black um
it's not drawing white has a move with
which
they can win and that move is bishop b7
let's see why
you have to play a 5. if you go king to
b6
we'll go bishop c8 obviously the bishop
is attacked we need to move it
a5 f4
push the pawns king's coming
push you have to stop
it and now
bishop g4 bishop h3 something like that
the point is that
now it is white that creates some kind
of a fortress
black's king is in zugsbank right you
cannot actually approach the pawn
so what we're gonna do with white we're
gonna win those pawns
okay and then we're bringing the king to
support our pawn and win the game
so if you play here we go here
and
and
no matter what you do now you know it's
game over you push a2 we take it b3 we
take it
so this is kind of the the cool idea if
in this position after king c2 you go
king c7
earlier remove the bishop obviously
but here we can we can create this
fortress again so we're creating it like
this
uh and so the king cannot suddenly make
it to e4 if it could
obviously it would be a draw but king
cannot really
make it in such a way to attack this
pawn and white will be able to support
it with the king
and if white manages to support this f
pawn with the king and stop those two
pawns with the bishop
white is clearly winning because they
have an extra bishop
um and um
yeah and instead of king d6
if you play a4 for example here
we bring in the king and whichever pawn
you push
you can't survive for like b3 for
example
you're not doing anything you're not
doing anything with this pawn because
if you push b2 the bishop goes there
right so we can even go here
and try to grab those pawns first
the bishop will stop it defend this one
we're in those pawns and then win the
game
uh another idea would be to maybe go
king to d4 to try to go grab
or not grab the punk because you cannot
but just attack the pawn like this
and then push those pawns in such a way
that
you will make him uh
and you'll keep him passive but no this
doesn't work
because i can even take
now it's very simple i just take that
pawn and then i'm winning the game
so bishop to b7 a5
in v2
yeah white is winning white is winning
in this position a4
in the game the the players drew as i
showed
previously in the first place and now
now here's the thing the correct move
here for white is king to a3
the point is now black's king needs to
move away so our king can go forward and
the pawn and the bishop together will be
able to create this fortress
so the black skin cannot approach the
pawn if black's king is close to the
pawn we can
always give up one of our pawns on the
other side
deflect the bishop take the pawn right
or be able to play king e3 king f4 like
it was previously as
as as the players agreed on a draw
but in this case we're putting black and
zugswang
if you walk in b6 we'll just move the
bishop back
you go back we push f4 and you cannot
really come close enough to attack
either one of these and then you cannot
push these pawns because the other one
will be lost
if you go king d4 to try to play king e3
once again very important
f4 and as you can see there's this
fortress
that stops black skin from approaching
the pawn which means that now
white is going to be able to or this is
what they want
in here try to take that pawn and wait
so you kind of have to go back and here
we
put black and zucchin we don't rush to
push this pawn forward
if you do that's what's going to happen
and now we go here he goes here and as
previously
the king's staying next to the pawn you
can never take this one because the a
pawn will go
and it's going to be a draw
um sorry so the correct move here is
bishop back
just giving them the move i love how
bishops give the move just like that you
just move it far away kind of like the
rook just
kind of like you learn when you're first
learning to play chess you learn how to
make king group versus king
here you know you learn that the bishop
can make a waiting move something that a
knight cannot do
um they are trying to get in front of
the pawn
king before going in front of the pawn
nope nope nope nope fortress again
now you will have to maybe push those
pawns or sit here
and now obviously don't take please
don't make this blunder because after
this it will obviously be the draw here
here here
takes the pawn so now what do we do
waiting move waiting move
you sit and wait and guess what
obviously we can still not take because
if we take we're not in the box of this
pawn anymore which is this one of course
and then they always push it forward
deflect our bishop
go for this f pawn so no we don't do
that we got king c5
he sits on weights that's why it was
important for the king to be next to the
pawn because that way you didn't have
time to do anything but in this case you
can do things and now look how beautiful
king here
you start pushing the pawn
whichever pawn you push a3 or b3 we got
bishop d5
so now we switch the position of the
bishop the king comes we're going to win
this
this um the bishop stops those two pawns
and we're going to win it as a king
opponent game and in the end of course
once you get that
drawing position you just make a bishop
move give the move
window the kingdom pawn in game if you
play b3
uh now the correct move for white here
is
king to c3 and then um
seats and weights because you cannot
push the pawns anymore the
king cannot approach this f pawn now we
go this way
and you see how great it is to have the
bishop on the same that on the correct
diagonal
it stops the pawn from promoting it
keeps our pawn
go forward and it also creates this
fortress that does not allow black skin
to approach the pawn
kind of crazy uh but i think i really
hope you guys
you guys like this one i remember the
first time i saw it i
definitely uh you know talked to ultra
and i wanted to make sure
this gets be in the book um because it's
definitely like a study and um
you only have one solution that helps
you it seems simple but it's not
as simple you see if you do have been
that simple wouldn't have been
spent about 20 minutes uh going through
it
so these
were some of the positions that
um that i wanted to share with you guys
today
from our book once again the book name
is the book's name is sherlock's method
it was co-authored by grand master el
shrimara di abani and myself
it's um it's a book that's supposed to
help you
uh get to
to train for a tournament it has
different parts
this is one of the parts and i share
some of the positions with you
there are many more interesting ones and
uh not
just king and pawn or study like there
are rook end games as well and
queen and games and others and complex
end games
or multiple psn games if you guys want
to purchase it check out
san luis chess clubs uh well
the club um
and um i don't know i
really really really hope that you
enjoyed
this insane end game video
i cannot wait for future videos
um here on the youtube channel of san
luis chess club
um and uh i hope to see you guys on
twitch
as well as on youtube next time
and um check out the book
with that said i wish you all a
beautiful
uh evening or morning wherever you are
and uh i'll see you in my next video
stay tuned for
other videos from the salary stress club
make sure to subscribe
so that you get notified whenever uh the
club is posting new videos
tons of material coming up each day lots
of stuff to learn
and hope to see you guys
soon bye for now